madame la Première ministre mardi
dernier un drame s'est produit avec la
mort du jeune Naël drame pour lequel
c'est encore le temps du deuil c'est
aussi le temps de la justice qui doit
suivre son cours dans le respect des
principes de l'État de droit
depuis des quartiers entiers dans nos
métropoles comme dans nos territoires se
sont enflammés plus de 5000 véhicules
incendiés 1000 bâtiments brûlés dégradés
au piliers des centaines de mairies
services publics au commissariat attaqué
ces exactions doivent être condamnées à
toutes force parce qu'elle détruisent
des biens communs elle détruisent des
familles entières et des experts de
nombreux acteurs qui sont tous les jours
sur le terrain l'État a répondu
rapidement et vigoureusement tant par le
nombre des forces de l'ordre mobilisées
que par les actions la justice très
rapidement mis en oeuvre je veux
d'ailleurs saluer ici le courage et le
sang froid des policiers des gendarmes
celui des pompiers bien sûr
mais je veux aussi saluer les mers
serviteur de la République qui ont été
au front jour et nuit depuis mardi ils
sont au centre de toute action ils sont
victimes souvent d'agression et même
désormais ce sont leurs familles qui
sont en première ligne c'est
inacceptable
sans eux notre République n'est rien ou
bien peu de choses et je sais qu'ils ont
jamais l'esprit libre ils sont ils ont à
leur côté tous les bénévoles de leur
conseil municipaux le corps enseignant
et le monde associatif au long de mon
groupe démocrates modernes et
indépendants je veux partir mon rendre
hommage aujourd'hui au maire et vous
demandez madame la Première ministre de
leur apporter tout le soutien dans le
gouvernement est capable il faut
d'urgence leur donner les moyens de
reconstruire les médiathèques les écoles
les antennes de police tous ces lieux
qui font le cœur de notre territoire et
qui donne le sens aux mots communiquer
communauté